oh boy well yeah one two two dragons
versus one white dragon yeah I don't
love those on overwhelming episode it
sort of felt like that I mean this
script I still really enjoyed the hell
out of that episodes long yeah
but the script of this episode and the
way a lot of scenes played out felt a
little bit like an action movie yeah
like anything to have as much of the
surprising that specific tailored type
of dialogue and I was like Game of
Thrones tends to have they were still
like surprises to be happy but even like
with the dragon being killed if the way
that was played out I feel like you know
old Game of Thrones might have made that
a little more surprising yeah the way
that was playing out if I hadn't even
known that I would have been like oh
he's gonna kill a drag yeah yeah this
dude nobody can even tell what this guy
is doing to you think about like of
course he's gonna say exactly and we've
already dodged this once with the big
cross yeah that they built on the in the
other battle yeah a lot of the banter to
seems a little bit like action movie
what would a ragtag team talk yeah yeah
yeah exactly and it's like I like that
partly because it's cool to jump around
between pairs of characters or a few
characters at a time and see what this
combination of them would talk about
what this animation would talk about but
I do get this the backlash on this
episode that it does feel a bit
Hollywood and it does feel a bit let me
burn like a really hasty plan huh it
feels very real very Hollywood and it's
like this season has been a lot of
fanservice and I've been loving it and
if people seem like they were really
psyched up until this point
yeah but the dialogue here started
feeling like a little fanservice II yes
still rewarding to watch they're still
like I like watching these characters
haven't interacted yet interact with
each other like watching torment and the
Hound interact was really fun and that
is how they would talk with each other
and yeah it does feel very Hollywood
like but it's like oh so where I expect
Game of Thrones to be by its finale you
know yeah as the show's wrapping up
and expected to really go any other way
when I sort of wonder if maybe like I
don't know the entire lineage of how
they changed what the finale of the show
and what the last two seasons were gonna
be because I wasn't it like two seasons
and they made it like one big season
split yeah half or something so I almost
wonder if maybe some of these details
were crunched down for a few of these
episodes because up until now it seems
like we've been taking our time and sort
of progressing in a careful way and this
episode by comparison this whole plan
getting the team misfits together going
up on the wall like it seems kind of
hastily assembled both in the context of
the show and just outside watching it
you know the way the plots have
progressed yeah it does feel like what's
happening right now and I can't tell how
long distance like the thing I've lost
track of in the past two episodes
especially is just how much distance
factors into anything mm-hmm
you know because like people go visit
other people I'm like wait I swore it
would take like weeks for this to happen
yeah what's going on with Ariane Sansa
it's coming you really on edge man yeah
I mean this whole seasons for a while
it's been feeling like what the hell's a
little finger even doing here seems kind
of useless now and then now we're he's
becoming an essential part of the plot
what's going on with Arya and Sansa
right yeah driving each other because
even now with him being involved in this
plot he's even still in the background a
lot yeah so I'm really wondering what
this show is gonna do with concluding
Littlefinger's character and then with
Arya and Sansa having them be toe to toe
with each other like I I saw the letter
was a big deal but then as REO and and
sanso we're having an argument I
suddenly really started to hit me like
oh this could [ __ ] everything up it
didn't dawn on me last episode that that
letter could destroy everything but this
time around like yeah this could destroy
it is everyone's about trust here and if
you lose trust you were [ __ ] the
battle scenes are really cool the dragon
dying sorry I'm not the best at
remembering every single name at a
thousand characters on Game of Thrones I
don't want more which dragazine that is
that's why I'm not gonna read the
comments on this video really like you
but
remember this one dragons there at the
top of your head plus in the script for
the next episode this happens yeah but
the dragon time was heartbreaking I'm
very happy that Johnson technically
bended the knee in his own way he
verbally bended the knee and will
torment wisdom living off their and
their hinting more and more at the big
reveal of who Jon Snow really it's like
we already know as the audience that Jon
Snow is the son of Rhaegar you know like
these characters told you like the last
episode Gilly Gilly points it out we see
Jon Snow is not really a bastard here
with the whole Danny my brother used to
say that yeah very good company yeah
very good company exactly I really feel
like if Game of Thrones is gonna be Game
of Thrones you gotta have John and Danny
hook up and then find out what he's got
to do it based on a different time and
yeah you know feedback yeah it's harder
to track lineages yeah look different
enough yeah my family they don't that's
the truth yeah I mean Rhaegar look like
her brother he does not look like he's
related to a Targaryen at all it seems
like things are moving along very
quickly now like whereas I feel like the
first part of this season was kind of
taking its time with the details and
like letting things sort of simmer and
build in the background sort of picking
them up over the storylines I feel like
we've kind of gotten really direct in
these past couple of yeah I'm kind of
conflicted about it cuz I really love
the way Game of Thrones has been all
these years
with all their seasons and in this
episode and that's why I think the word
is fanservice is because they are like
you said incredibly direct on everything
there's no more beating around the bush
yeah on a single thing but at the same
time there seems to be a lack I mean
there's been so much build-up for so
many seasons and all these things that
do we really need more build-up or at
the same time it's kind of conflicting
cuz you're like it's a little too direct
sometimes where you could use this is
one one long-ass finale this whole
season like everything's on the table
this one finale
they jumped between what three major
conflicts in this you know there's the
white Walker missions a lot of
characters on say yeah and and just see
Tyrion and Daenerys right yeah we didn't
see a lot of Daenerys as people we
didn't see Cersei or Jaime in this
episode no no and I really I really do
appreciate the relationship that's
warming between Tyrion and Danny J Danny
because that moment when Tyrion was like
don't go don't go we need you if you die
every I really you could see he really
feels for her and he only cares about
what he sees in her yeah granny he
points out [ __ ] that she does that he
finds flawed you know she has a temper
she sometimes makes poor choices which
is her hand he should point out he's
legit like that's their their
relationships you have that trust but at
the end of the day you see that Tyrion
just really believes in her yeah and he
felt in that moment that if she dies
everyone's doomed including himself they
like everything he's continued living
for his is screwed at that very moment
he's staked his entire life on her base
yeah like he's trying to make her
succeed and and I thought it was a
really smart writing choice to have the
dragon kill it makes everything way more
intense for a variety of reasons one it
shows that like yeah because the dragons
aren't now they're definitely not like
already with the dragon being pierced by
bronze when bran hit it crit drogue on
that was already like okay the dragons
are not invincible here you're like holy
[ __ ] the night king the holy [ __ ] the
white Walker is really harsh like
ultimate enemy because they they took
out that dragon like it was nothing yeah
there was nothing one Spears all you
need it yeah and that dude with the
greatest arm in the north
yeah greatest arm beyond the wall damn
that so it increases the fear there too
and plus her debt Daenerys to be there
makes it personally involved for her
because now she's on a vengeance mission
as well is that like she said those
dragon are her children you do feel that
in that scene that she lost a child and
when you lose a child man you gonna
verse ago John wick on those white water
yeah yes and I don't and I like the the
point she makes about uh I like the
point that she makes about it you know
it's better that I got to see them and
to know their power you know which yeah
you know as a plot device I think it's
good that they did that because I'm
thinking now it's like if they didn't go
on this mission that might not have been
possible so like even if this mission
itself is a bit of a clunky plot turn it
did get us to a place that we need to
kind of be in yeah and probably sooner
than later now especially because we've
got a lot of things converging a pretty
soon we needed it especially for John to
bend the knee because it John always has
his doubts and while he can have his
faith and belief in in conversations he
has with Daenerys when Daenerys comes
flying in saves their asses and all that
all that [ __ ]
then that's gonna make John really
believe in her and then he has a great
story to tell everyone in the north wait
Bennett [ __ ] me she know you'll get
it wasn't like you rode in with three
dragons Jill the bunches bunch of these
you saved us yeah and this is because
there's one [ __ ] we didn't see with a
big ice spear but it took her ten
minutes to fly three hundred miles it's
gotta be more than three but yeah like
you know across the water and I'm a
Thoreau's died I mean because for
another element that added to
action-movie s is a Mike I feel like old
game of throws were to kill off like two
to three of the big players I kept going
wait a minute do they have a bunch of
like randos in the back who we just
haven't like the hardcore Game of
Thrones fans you know every single
characters ambreena beleaguered this guy
you [ __ ] idiot like I know sometimes
it's shot in white words like unless you
really know their face I'm like wait a
minute whoa hold on cuz there's their
wide usually there wasn't there like
hordes of walkers and well the big death
was the dragon and Thorin Soros and I
like that they killed off Thoreau's
because with that that adds what's the
other guy's name Bella Berek Berek okay
I like Li they killed off Thoreau's
because i intensifies the stakes to for
barrack you
berrak relies on the guys to I'm sorry
yeah he relies on he relies on throws to
stay alive so that puts barrack has one
life left now it's like if he dies he's
dead one life to live and and when
Thoreau's dying i mean when he said the
birthing i was like yeah and when he
doesn't like okay there yeah it was but
was sad though cuz I like that character
I like the way I like his dialogue I
like the way to interact with the Hound
I really like that character a lot and
sad but at the same time home still
thinking like they would have killed off
like ol Gaiman I know how good these
guys are at fighting yeah yeah there's
like there's a moment yeah when they're
first running and the walkers are
chasing after him you're looking in the
background I'm like they're so far
beyond could they could easily have
murdered you alright coming at once yeah
yeah like if they want it to I honestly
I just feel like this should have been
so I feel like this might have been more
episodes worth they'd split all the
events of like the last episode and a
half into two or three episodes that
might have felt more natural cuz then
you could just put one entire episode
for this people not responding
positively to this episode there's been
a little bad Club really like what the
Hollywood thing like oh like this whole
plotline oh that's adding no we're
pointing out yeah I didn't know that I
really felt I really felt it's been all
the action movie show I don't know if
it's like the majority but I have seen a
few headlines and I have seen a few
videos go up people talking about like
after one of the haled is one of the
best episodes which was what five you
know with the the big dragon fighting
all that stuff for or episode 4 yeah
after one of the best episodes people
think that these last couple have been a
bit subpar because of this weird plot
turn where it's like we gotta go bag a
white Walker yeah and you know to be
fair I can I can see parts of that but
just the same there are things I still
like about each of these episodes you
know it just doesn't feel as smooth you
know I feel like this could have been a
couple episodes because this is the
second-to-last episode there's usually a
big battle moment or something you know
and it feels like they've spread out
their big battles into several battles
throughout this whole season now yeah
and it seems like at a certain point in
the last episode when this decision got
made
then we cut to like here's the intense
part of like three major relations
right away it's like here's that second
last episode finale battle you wanted
but also here's a huge bit of conflict
between Arya and Sansa and here's a huge
bit of conflict between a you know or at
least an important conflict between
Tyrion and Daenerys
I wonder what Sansa is gonna how that's
gonna turn out for them in the end I
really wonder how that's gonna turn out
I yeah if this if Game of Thrones
continues on the hollywood path i feel
like they're gonna find out little
fingers been planning this and i'm gonna
they're gonna be friends again and kill
a little finger or something you know
that's what i think would happen yeah
and i can't tell who he's working for
that's a good thing and i mean part of
this part of the magic of this whole
experience is that we won't know the
full context of everything until later
so it's like and this show is usually
pretty good at taking something you
thought was one way and showing you it's
another way and so i have no idea what
little fingers motivation is cuz
sometimes he'll surprise you with weird
foresight yeah where you're like yeah
this is gonna be ugly at first but it's
gonna lead to good things or he could
just be trying to destroy them because
you know he's in the mmm somebody else's
pocket yeah or his own pocket yeah
lookout only for himself yeah and it's
like he seems to have at least for Sansa
demonstrated an actual sense of care but
I can't you know tell if that's
opportunism and it seems like this could
be maybe he's trying to make her just
get re out of the way you know well what
do you guys think of the episode man
we'll be on top of the last episode Greg
will not be in Colorado this yeah we're
gonna watch it just in time to make sure
we don't get your [ __ ] spoiled for us
whatsoever
yeah I'm really I'm actually relieved
because I expected a dragon to die at
some point I did had to yeah yeah I
can't just be their magic thing yeah you
know I expected a dragon to die at one
point I'm sorry you got that spoiler for
you I'm really happy I missed that
spoiler yeah that it becomes a white
Walker
the very first thing I heard about this
is really that was the first thing yurt
yes that was not spoiled for a man
man yeah guys subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell -
on Humphrey on twits and insta and you
know patreon.com slash the real rejects
take care